vous avez manifesté la semaine dernière
à montréal dimanche vous vous apprêtez à
le faire encore aujourd'hui
l'invitation auprès du directeur du
service de police de montréal a fait
beaucoup de bruit
sylvain caron qui ne sera pas présent
finalement n'est pas le bienvenu votre
réaction là dessus ben oui effectivement
mais une des raisons vous louez ça fait
beaucoup de bruit alors c'est pas le bon
bruit donc le bruit c'est ce qu'il
faudrait faire c'est concernant la
brutalité policière et non quand le fait
qu' est-ce que le chef de la police doit
être présent ou pas donc je comprends
les organisateurs aussi il faut pas
oublier dans qu'il ya beaucoup de colas
il ya beaucoup de frustration envers la
brutalité policière donc
donc on ne veut pas que la lumière donc
les organisateurs ne veulent pas non
plus que la lumière soit pointé vers le
chef de police et pour ma part je dirai
aussi que c'est bien vous que des
personnes portant des dirigeants de
l'est du pays ou de la province sont
présents font belle figure
mais ce qui est très important c'est ce
concrètement qu'est ce qui va arriver
donc j'ai par exemple j'ai entendu hier
le chef de police dire qu'il est qu'il
avait une ouverture à ce qui est du
changement et moins personnellement je
trouve que tu en as encore c'est quand
même honteux de dire qu' il ya une
ouverture de faire des changements dans
distancer encore des mots je trouve qui
banalise tout ce qui se passe en ce
moment donc il y avait eu meurtre de la
brutalité policière qui se font depuis
des années on remonte avec les films à
peine plus d'autres personnes qui ont
étaient morts de façon gratuite dont de
dire qu'il ya une ouverture à un
changement mais pas assez donc c'est
comme dire que c'est pas grand chose
donc ça il est en train de préparer
actuellement une politique sur les
interpellations qui sera présenté en
juillet prochain
alors ça c'est quand même un geste
concret et est-ce que c'est suffisant à
vos yeux
pour l'instant ce n'est pas un geste
pour l'instant ce sont des paroles comme
depuis des années on entend encore des
paroles donc léger c'est lorsqu'on va
avoir justement des choses concret on va
enlever on va voir les gens les
dirigeants de ce pays de cette ville
vont vraiment passer à l'action pour
l'instant ce sont juste des paroles
comme on entend depuis 12 20 et en quoi
de votre côté quelles sont les solutions
que vous pourriez
par exemple proposé pour non seulement
dénoncer le racisme vraiment le
combattre des gens partant il ya une
éducation qu'il faut refaire au sein de
la police l'éducation ce qui pour
refaire au sein de la population
je pense que ce serait très important
regardez dans les écoles dans les écoles
on espère en défense des milliers des
millions pour ce qui a trait à
l'éducation sexuelle oui pour les
enfants donc qu'est ce qui fait qu'on ne
m'ait pas aussi des sauteurs
d'importance justement sur la
discrimination qui est un fléau et
normaux d'aujourd'hui donc ce serait
bien qu'ils aient une éducation qui se
fait belle école donc déjà on sait aussi
très bien donc elles dans les écoles
tout ce qui tout ce qui a été tout ce
qui a trait à l'esclavagé tout ce qui a
trait à ce que les autochtones ainsi
conçu dit aulas vicié ces inconnus de
personnes c'est maintenant que les gens
sont au courant de ce que les
autochtones exemple ont vécu ou à la vie
siècle quoi il ya un changement de ton
dans les manifestations actuellement aux
etats-unis vous l'avez certainement
remarqué aussi beaucoup moins de 15 se
passe de façon plus pacifique
est-ce que c'est également ce que vous
souhaitez pour ce qui va se passer au
jour de montréal effectivement c'est ce
que je choisis faut que ça se passe de
façon pacifique
on ne peut pas combattre la haine par la
haine donc c'est très important j'ai
parlé avec un visa organisateurs il a
pris vraiment énormément de précautions
malheureusement on n'est pas à l'abri
des cas ça vous savez dans une file
manifestations il ya des gens qui sont
là pour la cause et à des gens qui sont
là pour profiter de la cause et faire du
bruit donc moi j'étais à la semaine
passée la labellisation était ce projet
de 17 heures à 18h30 il moi je suis
resté de 7 à 18h30 ça s'est très très
bien passé malgré qu'il ya eu des
incidents par la suite mais qui avait au
clair avant avec les manifestants ou les
organisateurs de l'événement oui c'est
par la suite que ça a dégénéré la
semaine exactement